there are other things other than
carbons that might branch off of the
main chain and in this video I want to
introduce you to the alkyl halides so
alkyl alkyl halides
and this is a situation where one of the
halogen elements and the halogen
elements are the second to last or the
second to the right or to the rightmost
column in the periodic table fluorine
chlorine bromine iodine it's when one of
these replace one of the hydrogen's
attached to a carbon so I've drawn some
alkyl halides here and let's take a
little bit of how to name them so like
we name all of our organic molecules so
far you look for the longest chain first
the longest chain and the longest chain
that contains a double bond if there is
one in this case there is no double bond
so the longest chain looks like this we
start here and we go over there or we
could go either way but this is the
longest chain so it's one two three four
five six seven eight
carbons let me make sure that one two
three four five six seven eight carbons
and we want to start at the end where
we're going to run into either some type
of out some type of halide first or some
other type of branch off of it's just
something attached to the carbon chain
other than a hydrogen so we're going to
start at this end so it's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
and so we are deal if sorry 7 7 8 so
we're dealing with n-octane our main
chain has 8 carbons so we're dealing
with an octane and now we have to think
about these different halogens that we
have here so first we have a chlorine we
have a chlorine at carbon number 2 so
that's going to be 2 chloro 2-chloro is
what we're going to call that we're
going to put them in alphabetical order
and then put them in front of the octane
and then this is a this right here is a
it's on the fourth carbon so it is a 4
bromo the cotton the the actual element
is call
bromine we change the e to a to an or oh
so this is bromo bro or so and the e to
an oh I should say so this is bromo and
B comes before C but we're not done yet
because we don't have just halides here
we don't just have these halogens over
here we also have a methyl group we have
one carbon sitting over here so we don't
want to forget that guy so that right
there that is a 5 5 methyl so when we
write it all out we do it in
alphabetical order B takes precedence so
it will be this will be 4 bromo I'll do
it over here
4 bromo then the next thing we have is C
so for bromo to CRO chloro 2-chloro
5-methyl 5-methyl 5-methyl octane
5-methyl octane now if we take look at
this structure over here our main carbon
branch we only have two carbons in it
only have two carbons in it right here
so we're dealing with F or ethane it's a
single bond so this is this tells us
that we're dealing with an ethane and
let's see what we have attached to we
have a bunch of these halogens attached
to it we've replaced a bunch of our
hydrogen's with halogens so we have we
have these fluorines here and so we can
start we can start at the end we could
start at the end that has more of that
has more things attached to it so in
this case we have one two three
fluorines attached so this is going to
start off with and then fluorines well
I'll just leave it like that for now I
was going to write if I have to remember
you're going to alphabetize it so let me
just write out so it's at some point on
our in our name we're going to have
attached we're going to start here
that's going to be the one carbon that
is the one carbon that is the two carbon
so at one point in our chain
let me switch colors actually we're
going to have one two three fluorines so
it's going to be a try it's going to be
a tri fluoro tri fluoro and they're all
at the one carbon so it's going to be a
1 comma 1 comma 1 tri fluoro that'll
take care of those three fluorines there
and then we're going to have at some
point in our name
this bromo is attached to the two
carbons so two bromo and then you also
have this chloro attached to the 2
carbon so you're also going to have a 2
2 chloro so then you go in alphabetical
order B takes precedence and then you're
going to go to the C and then the tri
fluoro you ignore the tri but f still
comes after B and C so this is going to
be this is going to be to bromo to bromo
2-chloro 2-chloro I'm going to the same
shade of green to chloro - I didn't well
- chloro same idea - chloro and then we
have 1 1 1 1 1 1 tri fluoro tri fluoro
tri fluoro ethane tri fluoro tri fluoro
ethane now I want to make one thing
clear when you do this double bonds we
saw in the last video we learned a
little bit about alkenes still take
precedence over everything so if we go
to this original compound of this
original molecule up here if I were to
throw a double bond here so let's say I
threw a double bond then all of a sudden
that will change the naming mechanism
first of all we're not dealing with an
octane anymore we're dealing with and
we're dealing with or we're dealing with
an octene so in this situation the chain
will start at the end closest to the
double bond so this 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so
now this becomes 7 chloro this will be 5
bromo this is for methyl and this
compound over here
it will no longer be this thing over
here because I've added this double bond
it will now be going in alphabetical
order it would be five bromo five let me
have some space here it will be five
bromo five bromo seven chloro seven
chloro fluoro for methyl four four four
methyl and then we have acht but it's a
alkene so it's acht we have to specify
where we start our double bond acht two
acht to een now if we had two double
bonds let's say we had the situation
where it was this maybe we had let's see
we don't have to we can't don't want to
put too many bonds your carbon will only
have four bonds but this carbon has
three besides we could have a double
bond over here in that situation we're
going to have and I actually didn't
specify it correctly in the last video
so this is a bit of a correction this
instead of being too mean this will now
be let me make it instead of being two
een when I add that second carbon there
or that second double bond it will now
be we scroll over to the right a little
bit
it will now be acht - we have a double
bond at the two starting at the two and
at the four 2 comma 4 and it's no longer
just an e that was a mistake that in the
last video I said hepped and i just put
an e now that has two double bonds it's
a dying die e so don't want you don't
want to forget that that tells us that
we have two double bonds here although
it's kind of obvious because i'm listing
a 2 and a 4 so it's a little bit
redundant 2 & 4 dying so if you have it
with these two double bonds we have 5
bromo 7 chloro for methyl acht 2 for
dying and the whole reason why i
introduced this is really to make a bit
of a correction well to show you two
things one that the double bond takes
precedence when you are
deciding which direction to number in
and then also to correct a little bit of
a mistake in the last video where I did
I forgot to put the die when I had two
double bonds